Nhiều bà mẹ tháng 5 năm, ngày hôm 12 mấy sau tại đất lắc sế ra vụ việc khá hiểu.
Theo đó, một bây tra 12 tuổi đã từ ý mà cửa xe uto của mình khác,
môi vào cái lãi và điều khiến xe chạy quan vô con hệ.
Lên quan đến tụ việc, chi hết, bà mê bà tuổi, chú phần buồn hộ, tình đất lắc,
cho biết, chỉ là người đăng đoạn clip để cạnh báo các gia đình về việc chủ quan để triệu quả trên xe.
Thưa chị, chị xe nói trên là của gia đình mình, khoảng mây giờ cùng ngày, trong chị dừng xe trước,
gió giữa xưa xuất anh đã để quyến triệu quả trên xe và đi vâ nhạc.
Lúc sau, một bây tra 12 tuổi xống gần đó, một cửa xe và tự điều khiến xe chạy về những nhà mình.
Quả chính giết chuyện quan nhiều con hệ, chiếc oto xe ra vá quả tiệ vui một xe tắc xe.
Phát hiện sự việc bất thường, tắc xe tắc xe yêu cầu bẻ tra dân xe,
đồng thời đưa cho qua lại nhà chủ xe để tông báo, theo chủ xe buộc chỉ khiến oto bị xức nhẹ.
Tuy nhiên, giống biết cho bẻ có hình cạnh khó khăn và có biểu việc bất thường về tâm lý,
nên ra đến chỉ không yêu cầu vô tương tế thải.